so the telephone I'm afraid my protocols
are being overridden you have reached
the life model decoy of Tony Stark
please leave a message
this is urgent then leave it urgently
security breach
Sonia mr. stark yeah come in Phil I
can't stay his first name is agent
Dunham we're celebrating it's just wine
he can't stay we need you to look this
over as soon as poss I don't like being
Hannah things because I love to be
handed things so let's trade thank you
official consulting hours are between
8:00 and 5:00 every other Thursday this
isn't a consultation this is about the
Avengers which I know nothing about the
Avengers initiative is scrapped I
thought and I didn't qualify I didn't
know that either yeah apparently I'm
volatile self-obsessed and play well
with others
dad I didn't know this isn't about
personality profiles anymore whatever
mr. Potts got a second
you know I thought we were having a
moment I was having 12% of a moment this
seems serious bill he's shaken how would
you notice
why is he filled what is all this this
is this
I'm going to take the jet to DC tonight
tomorrow you have homework a lot of
homework well what if I didn't if you
didn't you mean when you finished well
squared your flesh
so any chance you're driving by
LaGuardia I can drop you tastic
you
you